Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are talking about
your first kiss stories
and ours as well.
We're gonna get all of this
because this is our first episode back
from taking a three week 2020 break.
A twee week bweak.
We took a twee week bweak.
And speaking of first, right at the top.
Boy, it sounded a little weird.
Did you add a little something?
Did you notice something was different?
I did because we've discussed it.
Not as much as I would be comfortable,
not as much as I needed
to be comfortable enough.
You know, I'm very proud of you
that we were--
I just like going for it.
We remembered!
We decided to put the slogan.
That new slogan at the top.
Well, we actually talked
about this like a year ago
that we were going to try to find a way
to encapsulate what this podcast is,
so anybody who happens to be
tuning in for the first time
would understand what it
is right from the top.
Yeah,
but when you're doing it
and you've done this podcast
for so long and you've
done it in different ways,
and I also have done it,
it's kind of hard to know.
You're real close to it.
And we talk about so many things
and have tried so many
things that it's hard to say,
well, this is what this podcast is,
but that's what we've landed on.
Maybe it will help you as you tell people
about this podcast that
you enjoy listening to.
Two lifelong friends.
Nope, not lifelong.
Two.
Yeah.
Yep, not best friends though.
Two lifelong best friends.
Well, I mean--
We are best friends.
We are,
but my vote was to not include it in this
just because it sounds like
a better slogan without it.
Two lifelong friends talking
about life for a long time.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
About life for a long time.
Not a really long time 'cause--
No, just a long time.
By a long time we mean
just like podcast length.
Like an hour.
So it's not really a long time.
Okay, if you were told you
need to go talk to this person,
and then you were like, "Well, how long?"
And somebody said, "An hour,"
that's a long time.
That's a long time.
But if you said, "You need
to listen to this podcast
"where two lifelong
friends talk about life
"for a long time."
It'd be like well, it's
a podcast where they talk
for a long time,
so you're talking like, three hours?
Nope.
You're taking the long--
And applying it to podcasts.
Signifier and applying
it across all podcasts.
I'm just talking about normal commerce.
Standard conversational
podcast is an hour-ish.
And the most popular podcast in the world,
by the way,
is like three hours on average.
Yeah, so an hour is not a long time, so.
So that's good,
and what I'm saying is it's good.
It's good that--
It's kind of like leading with a negative.
It's like, oh, they
talked for a long time.
You'll have to get used to that.
Well, it's just an hour?
Oh, that's just a podcast.
This is why I'm glad we
didn't have to discuss it
because this is what the
discussion would have been.
And then you would have lost heart.
But I love it.
And you would have gotten frustrated.
But I love the fact that you
gave in and we just said it.
I haven't given in.
It can change.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits
where two lifelong best friends
talk about life for an hour.
So I don't have any problem.
You keep adding best,
and you are my best friend,
and we are best friends.
And I'm changing the second part too.
I'm not practicing what you told me.
I'm iterating.
Okay, but that doesn't help.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
There's no word play in that.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about, not discuss.
Yep.
Discuss is a little too self-important.
It's like, oh, these are important topics
and we're gonna turn them over
and we're gonna come to conclusions.
Now we're just talking.
Right, I never said discussion.
You added that.
Yeah,
and you know what?
But you've also taken
out life for a long time,
which is kind of the only reason I liked
what I came up with.
The podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
You do like it!
I was kind of searching for it.
But you found it because it's natural.
I need to just go for a drive
and say it about 80 times.
Is that how you do things?
So what if it is?
But like, there's so much
else in life to experience.
No, it's just how I internalize something
that you have to say the same way a lot.
You underestimate, you came
up with this catchy phrase
and it made sense in your mind,
but then I have to transfer it to my mind.
If I had have come up with it,
you would have make sense
of it in your own mind.
You'd have to come to terms with it.
I don't think it's a lot
to make sense of though.
And if that required you
driving and talking to yourself,
I wouldn't ridicule you.
I think it would have
required you telling it to me.
And then I would have
been like, "That's good."
Can we start over?
But me say that part and
you say the other part?
Yeah, yeah.
I will buy your lunch if you get it right.
If you get it exactly
right on the first time,
I will buy your lunch.
Can I pick what it is too?
Yeah.
Okay, even if it's something that's aw,
that's not very healthy?
Even if it's unhealthy.
I don't believe you're gonna get it right.
Okay, here we go.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends discuss, shoot!
No, I knew it, I knew it!
Welcome Ear Biscuits,
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
That was it, but--
If you consider 60
minutes or so a long time.
You don't get your lunch now.
I get a lunch.
I'm so shiny right now.
I'll just pay for it.
I'm gonna get a tissue.
The second part of this is, fine,
go get a tissue.
Well, we had to cut the AC off
because again we're not in our studio.
Well, we haven't said that.
We also said this week at the
round table of dim lighting,
and I dunno if it sounds
a little different,
but if you're watching this,
it does look different,
'cause we're not at the
round table of dim lighting.
That's the other thing.
This is another first.
We are in our creative house.
Now,
we got everything set up.
We even got the sign here.
This is not a permanent move by the way.
We're going back to the
round table of dim lighting.
I mean, it could be.
It could be,
but so far I don't like it.
It's a move of out of necessity.
There's construction going
on at the studio right now,
including in the Ear Biscuits room.
And so we have moved things over,
but we actually took some time
so that it would be a better experience.
We're not using our USB mics.
We're using the actual
setup that we typically use.
And we did bring the sign like Link said,
and there's some soundproofing,
so hopefully it doesn't sound
so echoey in here, but--
We're a little close to each other.
We're a little closer and
the lighting is not dim.
Like, I could easily
poke both your eyes out.
This is not the round
table of dim lighting.
It is a round table though.
We talked about bringing the round table
and then they tried to
disassemble it and--
They realized somebody
had glued it together.
Yeah, it cannot come out of the room
without being destroyed.
Well, you could probably just,
yeah, if you just cut the legs
off and then refastened them.
Yeah, re-glue 'em.
Yeah.
So here we are.
We've already experienced two big firsts,
a new catchphrase explanation
at the top of the episode,
and being in here for the first time.
That's just by way of summary.
Now we can move forward.
I think we decided to
talk about first kisses
because we were talking about it being
the first episode back from our break.
And we do have some stories
from you of your first kisses
and we'll get in all that
in a little bit, but--
Wasn't much of a break.
Usually when we take a
break and we come back,
we have so much to update each other on.
Well, and it was a three week
break for you, the listener.
But it's less than three
weeks since we recorded
the last podcast of the last season.
So, but I think
nothing is happening.
This is the feeling
of COVID life.
Yeah!
It's like, you're looking
for something to be new.
And even when you think
things are gonna be new,
especially in California, it's like,
"Oh, you gotta pull it back."
And I agree with the pull back.
Yeah.
But it's just disheartening.
Well, I think something happened
when summer rolled around.
I mean, first of all,
everybody had this secret hope
that the virus would go away
during the summer, right?
And there was some,
even though scientists were saying
that that probably wouldn't happen,
there's some reason to believe
that viruses wouldn't be
as serious during the summer.
But it turns out that
doesn't have any effect
on the coronavirus.
So, but just the fact that even
when you live in California
and it's not like there's
a real big seasonal change,
but life is different
during the summer, right?
The kids are out of school
and you go on vacation, you travel.
We were planning on going back
to North Carolina during July
and seeing our families
and that's not happening.
And our kids were already out of school
and they're still just
out of school.
Out of school.
So they're at home and
you see the same people
all the time.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out...
I'm at a different place now.
I remember when we hit day 50
and I think it was in a vlog.
I don't know if it made the edit,
but I was like 50 days in quarantine.
I no longer count.
I no longer have any interest in knowing
how many days it's been.
Because I mean, we've been very
conservative in terms
of staying quarantined.
And so even as some things loosened up,
not for us.
And this is not to judge anyone,
but this is just in an
effort to keep our crew safe
when we get together and shoot.
But like, we don't even
go to the grocery store.
Like we don't go in any place.
The only place I've been indoors
with the exception for like,
maybe three minutes at a bike shop
that was had two people inside of it.
Other than my house, that's it.
We don't go inside.
We get our groceries delivered
or we pick them up curbside.
Yeah.
It's just more of the same.
And I no longer account.
Yeah.
I mean, are you counting?
Can you--
I did not count originally,
so I wouldn't know where to start.
Yeah, 'cause 50 days I was like 50 days,
what a huge deal.
We were talking about this earlier,
and I'm not a routine-oriented
person, right?
I don't like to do the
same thing every day,
but something about us not traveling
and not doing much besides shooting GMM,
shooting this show,
coming to the creative
house and doing the stuff
that we're doing like on TikTok
or the social media stuff,
it's made my mornings way
more predictable, right?
And so I'm not going to the gym,
I'm working out in my garage.
I'm doing my back stuff.
My exercises, my meditation,
and I've never done those.
Like, you get the little
alerts on your app
that say that like--
It's time to meditate.
For 10 days in a row or 20 days in a row.
I think I got to like 30
days in a row at one point.
Skipped a day, had to start over,
but I've never been that consistent
with any of those things,
and even though I'm stir-crazy,
there's something about
getting into that rhythm
of exercising and meditating
and actually having time
for reflection and journaling, even,
even journaling,
I feel like I'm in a pretty good place.
Yeah, and that makes me
angry at myself, not at you,
because the opposite happened with me.
Like right at the beginning,
and I talked about this,
I was like, I'm buckling down on routine,
'cause I always love routine.
And it's like, I now have
a opportunity to do more
of the things I want to do
incorporated into my routine every day.
I can work out and
meditate on the same day,
whereas before I would have to alternate
or something like that.
And I went, I think it was
50 days in a row meditating
because the app kept up with that and--
That's a lot.
And then after that,
it says your record was that,
and now you've done two days in a row.
Yeah, you gotta work back up to it.
I've never done more than four
days in a row since I broke
the streak of 50.
Oh.
And I was working out
and I stopped doing that.
I just got out of that.
'Cause my shoulder started hurting again,
and I got discouraged.
And then it's like, oh, you
sleep a little bit later?
And then I get down on myself about it.
So I tried it,
and then I was like, as long
as I just walk every day.
You gotta keep doing something.
Right.
You gotta stay active.
And so I just shifted from working out
'cause of my shoulder
to just walking and listening to a book.
And then I got done with my book
and it started getting
really hot really early.
Yeah.
And now I don't--
It's very high in this room.
Can I just say that?
I like it.
I worked out this morning.
So my internal temperature,
it's really high right now.
Yes, so you look at me.
You shouldn't work out, man.
I'm sweating.
You just wake up a little bit later.
Don't feel as bad about yourself.
I mean, there's like a flirtation
with a form of depression here.
I think it's 'cause
that's just the natural.
I mean, when you're cooped up,
that's not your way of life.
It's difficult.
And that's the kind of,
I was talking about this in therapy.
I was like,
I do feel a little guilty, right?
Because the average person,
most people I know,
are having a really difficult time.
And I thought that, oh man,
this is gonna be really difficult for me
because I like things to be shaken up.
I like to go places.
I like to go out.
I don't like eating at home.
You know what I'm saying?
But all I'm doing is eating at home.
Yeah.
But to me, it's a testament to the power
of exercise and meditation.
I dunno which one is more,
but something about there
is this prophylactic effect
of exercise on your mental wellbeing.
And exercise and meditation.
What?
You mean, it's like a condom?
Like a condom for your mind.
No, but what I'm saying is
that my experiences right now,
the circumstances,
and I'm not saying I haven't been down
and I haven't had days of depression
and sort of just like listlessness
and just feeling like
I can't get motivated.
I mean, there's been a couple of times
we're working on a couple of things
that require some writing.
And some days it'll be like, oh,
I could do this all day.
And then some days it'll be like,
I got nothing for this,
but that's sort of typical anyway, right?
You don't always have it.
But I was talking to
my therapist and saying
that there's just
something about I've never
ever been this consistent
with my daily practice
of exercise and meditation.
And I'm experiencing the benefits of it.
And like I said, I feel guilty,
but also I'm reminded that
when things do get back to normal,
because they will,
we will start going into the office.
We'll start traveling again.
We'll start going to things
that kind of shift your schedule around,
knock you out of your routine,
getting home late from something.
Getting home late, what is that like?
I'm home every single night.
I'm home already, you know?
Yeah.
And so the idea of having
that routine shaken up.
And walking too, I'm
doing a bunch of walking
and I didn't do any walking at all.
Like I'm seeing parts of the neighborhood
that I've never seen.
And so I have this like desire to okay,
how do you hold onto this?
Because I feel like if
I can take this practice
into my normal busy life,
when things get normal again,
I'm gonna be better off.
But I know I'm not gonna
be able to keep up with it.
It's just the fact that I
have the freedom to do it
is the only reason that I'm
being so consistent right now.
But I mean, it's so hard to
process what you're saying.
Like I said, it makes me
feel angry or just frustrated
because I just feel like
if you're not in that place,
hearing somebody say they're in that place
doesn't encourage you to be in that place.
At least for me, it's like, "Well."
I think if I started working out
and doing something more consistently,
I think that would help me.
But maybe I just need
to say, "You know what?"
"It's okay to just not do
that for a little while."
And it is okay.
Because I have to be ready
to launch back into something.
But I do think I feel the
cumulative problems associated
with not doing that.
You know?
Right?
Because I do think it
spills into you get so antsy
with everything else that
we are not able to do
in the way we want to do it.
Yeah.
You know?
And that's the weird thing.
The fact that we're not
working on something
that is taking us out of
the office and into meetings
and you know what I'm saying?
Like that's--
People interaction.
That's like what I live
for is the dynamic nature
of our jobs, right?
I mean, we have a lot that is
the same over and over again,
but we have a lot that
makes it very dynamic
and it makes it interesting
and you're collaborating,
and you're trying new things,
and most of the things people never see,
but we're working on things.
And that's why I can only
go back to, "Well, what's?"
"Oh, it's because I'm
exercising every single day."
It's like, I'm not having
time to let those thoughts
and those frustrations,
which under any other circumstances
would make me feel down
and make me feel depressed.
So yeah, to me, it's just like,
okay, I gotta remember this.
I just gotta remember it.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm just trying to be better.
I'm sorry if I
made you feel worse.
But I'm just saying--
Hey, you're speaking your truth.
It's separate from me.
And I'm all I'm saying is that as someone
who has thankfully not
stopped these processes,
I think that's the only thing
keeping me together right now.
'Cause it's definitely
not in most circumstances.
Yeah.
Right?
And again, it's like,
we don't have nearly as many worries
as a lot of people.
Oh, yeah, right.
You know?
So let's move on.
We're gonna talk about kisses.
First kisses.
But first we're gonna
talk about mythical.com.
It's a website we started a while back.
Lots of good stuff.
There's always something to
surprise you at mythical.com.
The good mythical summer T-shirt.
Check that out.
This thing will make you happy.
Sometimes it's just about
putting on the right thing,
deciding to get fully dressed,
and just seem ready for life.
Like, brush your teeth,
put on some clothes.
And if you put on the right shirt,
even though you may not
be experiencing the summer
that you're used to,
the good mythical summer T-shirt
might be that little extra
thing that you needed.
We're not doing it in
tank-top this year, right?
The tank option?
I don't know.
Because I could use a tank-top right now.
I'm feeling like--
There's some tank options
that are gonna be happy--
It is so hot
under my arms right now.
In the mythical store.
There's tank options?
Well, I think that's in the works, yeah,
but I don't know if it's of this shirt.
I can't remember right now.
Well I request one of those.
You got some water-skiing
fish-head people.
I mean, that is just fun.
Yeah.
Mythical.com.
You know what?
I feel better now.
I feel totally better!
You thought about selling T-shirts
and that made you feel better?
Yeah.
Before we talk about kisses,
we didn't talk about what's on your nose.
Is it noticeable?
I don't know if you can see it on camera,
but I mean,
I asked you about it and you were like,
I'll tell you on the podcast,
so I'm gonna have to ask.
Okay, is it a scab?
It's a scratch.
'Cause when I got up this
morning it was a bloody thing.
The end of my nose just had a bloody scab.
It looks like it just happened.
Oh, really?
It looks like you just got
scratched by a bobcat.
Last night...
Was it a bobcat?
No, it was a tree.
Oh.
I was throwing some Frisbee with my boys.
We like to go out and throw
some Frisbee, you know?
In the street?
In the street, yeah.
And Lincoln threw the
Frisbee up in the tree
and it was just high
enough where if I jumped,
I think I could grab the Frisbee.
'Cause I shook the limbs in the lemon tree
and it didn't fall.
And that's not a euphemism,
you actually have a lemon tree?
Right,
and so then I was like, I
can jump and I can grab it.
But what I didn't take into account
was in between where I
would jump and grab it,
there were a bunch of other limbs.
Yeah.
So when I jumped up--
The lower limbs, they call it.
The lower limbs that were right there.
You know when you're
focusing on something,
things closer to you get out of focus.
Just let this be a lesson.
So I raised my hand and it
was like Superman taking off,
like fist in the air,
except that all of these limbs
that were apparently
just inches from my face
before I started to jump--
Were now in your face?
Were just, like, I
jumped right into limbs.
Oh, it could've been worse.
I mean, thank God I wear glasses.
Right.
You know?
Even if I had 20/20
vision without glasses,
it turns out I would
need to wear them just
for like, eye protection.
Kurt Rambis.
Yeah.
I mean, I could have lost
my eyesight last night.
But instead it hit my glasses
and it hit the end of my nose.
And I'm like, man, that really hurt.
And when I went inside,
there was like a big bloody spot there
on the end of my nose.
There's a life lesson here.
Don't get so focused on the Frisbee
that you lose sight of the limbs
right in front of your face.
I think the life lesson is use a broom,
get a broom.
Yeah, that's a--
Why jump when you can get a broom?
Interesting that we
had similar situations.
This morning I had to grab
a suitcase for my wife,
which we keep stacked up
on this shelf in the garage.
Okay.
Because she's taking a little beach trip
with the kids.
A sabbatical from you.
And then I later will join them.
But
so it's up high,
and I was like, "I can't reach that."
I could potentially jump to grab it.
But I'm 42.
There's limbs in your face?
I'm 42, I don't jump for things.
So many things could go wrong.
So I grabbed a golf club
because that was the thing
that was closest to me,
but I couldn't get either side,
neither the grip nor the club head
to get under the handle--
Underneath the handle.
Because the handle, it was
one of those Away suitcases.
And so they're like, flush
until you pull on them.
Do you got a step ladder?
Yeah, but that was on the other side
of the garage.
Of the garage?
Oh goodness.
I'm 42, you can't walk across your garage?
Mr. Still Working Out
Everyday can't walk over
to a step-ladder.
No, no, I can.
It's just, I don't know if I should.
Okay?
But then I was like, shoot, man.
I actually did think to myself,
"You've been working out."
"You can jump, you can jump up there."
And thankfully there were
no lower limbs in the way.
There was nothing but air
between me and the suitcase.
You jumped?
I jumped,
and it was like, first try
slipped my fingers right under
the handle and beckoned
the suitcase my way.
Then when I came back down,
I did the smart thing,
I released as I was coming back down,
so as to leave it dislodged
but not falling on me.
Uh-huh.
And then I was able to do a baby jump,
grab it and pull it down.
Did it hit you in the face?
No, no, no, no facial injuries.
No life lesson to be learned, I guess.
No, I just got the suitcase.
You know, I think what you
described is not unlike
a first kiss.
You've gotta really work up your gumption.
You gotta convince yourself
that you can go for it.
You gotta think about it.
And then you gotta reach up,
and you gotta have a
gentle sort of caress.
Well, you should be gentle.
Based on some of these stories,
that is not always the case.
The moment where you
can really latch on is
when you should let go,
and then go for a second.
Delicate jump.
You talking about a tease?
No, just, there's plenty
of time for a second kiss.
The first kiss should not
try to be the end-all be-all.
It's virtually impossible.
Now we've done an episode,
I believe it was episode 114,
about first kiss stories.
Uh-huh.
And when we decided to do
this episode, we were like,
"Oh, it's our first episode back.
"First, first, first.
"First kisses, let's do that!"
And then we didn't even
realize we had done an episode.
Right.
This is not an uncommon issue with us.
Until Kiko pointed it out.
Right.
But I think subconsciously we're looking
for any chance to talk,
and our wives support this assertion,
to talk about our first kisses
or our first girlfriends
or our second girlfriends.
You know, we always go back to them.
But in that episode we did
share our first kiss stories.
I think we can revisit them a little bit.
If you haven't heard that,
we'll give you the gist of it
and maybe have a different take on it.
If you're really interested,
you can go back and listen to that.
We had a couple of stories
from listeners in there.
And then we had a couple
of crew members come on
and tell their stories,
but we got some good stuff from you guys.
Yeah.
So we'll keep our recounting
our stories relatively short
since we've told them before.
And we've actually told them
outside of the podcast as well.
But the update on my story is
that you actually had the
privilege of being with me
when we visited the
location of my first kiss
during our trip back to Buies Creek,
and I invited you to reenact it with me.
And then we showed that on LTAT.
You made me hold your hand.
And I mean, there was no kissing.
Right.
That's true.
I didn't go for it.
But I wasn't comfortable
with getting close to that.
Yeah, I could tell.
It was at the--
It was at the fountain.
So that video's on an episode of LTAT
that aired after our Buies
Creek documentary episode
from I guess last year.
But I'm gonna give you a little background
I'm not sure I've given before.
And of course I had begun dating,
or going with is what we
called it at the time, Amber,
and I knew that tonight was the night.
I don't know how long we'd been going out,
but it was like you
start going with somebody
and then you start kissing 'em;
this is the order of things.
Well, the order of things
is that I date Amber
and kiss her first.
She's my first kiss.
Right.
And then you date her after me
and she becomes your first kiss.
Did you actually date her?
Yeah.
For how long?
But you just kissed her that time
and then probably didn't kiss her again?
Well, okay, so I--
Right or wrong?
I can't imagine that you kissed her again.
I don't--
That would be very surprising to me.
I don't remember.
'Cause that was seventh grade.
Yeah, it was seventh grade.
I don't think I kissed her again.
I did.
Do you want to tell your story first?
It was at a birthday party at
the Lillington Ruritan building
and there was like a big open dance floor.
Nobody was dancing.
What is a Ruritan?
I dunno.
It's people who ruritate.
Is it like they broke off
from the Puritans?
So like, "Yeah, we're not
quite as pure as the Puritans."
Or maybe they ruined the Puritans.
Yeah, I think they decimated the Puritans.
They decimated the Puritans?
They tainted the Puritans.
We rurinted them.
So it's like a place of debauchery,
which, interesting, is
why you kissed there.
We were sitting beside each
other shoulder-to-shoulder
in these like folding chairs
that were like on the
edge of a dance floor
that nobody was dancing on and--
The best.
Michael and Anna
were sitting next to us,
and basically they sent me the message
that I was supposed to kiss Amber.
This was the time, you know?
Amber wanted me to kiss her,
but like, we didn't
communicate about this.
It was just Michael looking
over at me and saying,
"Go for her."
Yeah.
Yeah, so I went in for the kiss,
and the story goes that he timed it.
I can't remember how many seconds it was.
I can't remember what I said
how many seconds it was.
You have to go back and
listen to the three years ago
when I told this story.
But Michael timed it?
We knew.
Yeah.
And I mean, it was multiple seconds.
Like, I'm gonna say
either seven, nine or 14.
I don't know what I said before.
And I was more reliable
in telling the story then
than I am now,
'cause I haven't thought about
it probably much since then.
We need to connect with Michael,
because Michael plays a pivotal role
in my story as well.
Because I mean, not only
was he there with...
It wouldn't have been
with Anna in eighth grade.
That would have been you
or it would have been?
That was me, yeah.
He was with Anna in seventh grade.
Who was he with that night?
Anna.
No, who was he with at eighth grade?
My night.
Who was he with?
I don't know.
He was always with somebody though.
He was always with somebody.
And he had confidence.
The thing for me when I revisit
the story was that I did it
because I felt like I should do it.
Like, I didn't have a
sex drive at the time.
I didn't.
I mean, I was a late bloomer.
Yes.
It came later.
I guess no pun intended.
But it was like, "I gotta do this."
You felt pressure, you felt pressure.
Yeah, I mean, it was literally like,
you need to make out.
You felt external pressure.
I felt internal pressure, like a geyser.
Like a literal Geyser.
And it was a long kiss.
I remember she was on my right.
So I had to go over and my
head tilted to the left.
And I mean, it was a French kiss.
It was like, okay.
As I've said, many times, I was like,
I gotta be ready for this.
I had practiced on my bed post.
Right.
It might be a little
odd that that same bed
is still in our house
and Lando sleeps in it,
but it is painted.
Have you told him that?
No.
Have you showed him which post it was?
Son, come here, let me show you something.
It was a round post.
A very face-like post.
But it was like a head.
It was like making out
with a shrunken head.
Yeah, her head is at least four times
the size of that bedpost.
So that was probably
difficult to navigate.
And it was just a wood veneer.
It was a stained wood.
Yes, it had no mouth.
But it wasn't white paint like it is now.
It's not nearly as kissable.
And also the wall of my shower.
And this has--
This is so interesting.
I never practiced.
This has come up
in conversation recently
because of that TikTok
where I made out with
myself in the mirror.
Yeah.
And I mean, it definitely brought back
that memory of me making
out with my bedpost.
Did you learn anything?
I just don't think I would learn anything.
The shower's better because it's wet.
I mean, it's too wet,
but at least you know, hey,
in a really wet kiss situation
I can still find my way.
I don't know why it never crossed my mind
that I needed to practice with a wall.
'Cause you were so driven and motivated
to make out with your girlfriend.
But to me it was the pressure of like,
I gotta know how to do this.
I'm supposed to do this right now and--
Yeah, I wasn't thinking
about anything other than
I felt like I was about
to pull back the curtains
on the most amazing thing
I will ever experience.
It was just all anxiety for me.
And you know, it actually wasn't bad.
My recollection of it was
that the kiss wasn't bad.
I mean, it wasn't Amber's first kiss.
And she helped me out.
She did.
She carried her weight and more.
And there was a clockwise
motion to the tongue situation.
Clockwise?
There was like a circular
dance happening in there.
And I was like, oh, this is okay.
This is what we're doing.
You know?
Yeah.
'Cause I mean, there was no internet.
You couldn't be searching for how to kiss,
how to French kiss.
And there was no one I
would talk about it with.
But there were movies.
I think I just went off movies.
But even that, I mean,
you're not inside of the mouth.
You don't know exactly what's
happening with the tongue.
You can tell.
You can tell there's some
tongue exploration going.
Whenever I looked at that,
I was always just too
embarrassed to study it.
And of course I didn't
watch a lot of movies.
I didn't watch all those
make-out 80s movies.
That's why you had to
practice with your shower,
'cause you didn't watch movies.
That is a fact.
There's a lot I'm learning right now.
So the kiss itself was
not a bad experience,
but everybody was watching.
For someone to be so anxious
about it and to feel like,
oh, I gotta do it,
and then it's like, hey,
the entire party, it
felt like, was watching.
It wasn't even dark.
It was just dimly lit.
Yeah, that's weird.
Given all the circumstances,
I think I did pretty damn well.
I mean, Amber didn't dump me immediately.
She didn't dump me because
I was a bad kisser.
She dumped me because I was
just a ball of nerves probably.
And I actually wasn't into
dating as a seventh grader.
Right.
It was just too early for me, you know?
Well, my experience is a little different.
I'm in my own head!
My experience was a little different.
It was dark.
There was a fountain.
No one was watching--
Because you took her out there.
I had not practiced.
I had on my blue Nike sweatshirt.
I knew I looked like a million bucks.
I knew I smelled good.
This is before there was such
a thing as Axe body spray,
but there was deodorant.
Right Guard.
Okay.
Probably put a little on my neck.
Like a little blue residue?
That was cologne.
Or a little white residue.
That was cologne in 1991.
It was like, I'm gonna put
a little bit on my neck.
I mean, we were watching
movies with our girlfriends.
and then you ask Amber to go outside.
All of a sudden, you and Amber just leave
and take a walk.
I knew what I was up to.
And we're like, "Okay, see you later."
And this is where Michael Juby,
I'm going first-name, last-name now,
this is where Michael
Juby comes into play.
I've got a theory about
Michael Juby, okay?
Does it involve his dad?
No?
Okay, mine does,
but go ahead.
Oh, I--
Just go ahead.
I know what you're gonna say.
You're gonna say that his
dad taught him everything
and taught him how to have confidence,
which is true.
Yeah.
But I have a much more
complex theory than that.
Okay, okay.
You ever think to yourself--
Sometimes the simpler
theories are the more elegant.
You ever think to yourself, man,
if I could go back to high
school, middle school, whatever,
with the current mind that I have
and mentality, right?
Sure, absolutely.
You think about how you would
navigate things so differently.
Yes.
And so--
Especially yeah,
with this whole ball of nerves situation?
Yeah, yeah, especially in your case.
But I actually think the same thing.
I mean, I think about things like, man,
sometimes I wish I could just go back
even just the way I
approached playing basketball.
Sure.
Like why did I was so stupid
about the way I approached it
in so many ways.
But anyway,
I believe that Michael
was an adult who wished,
who was given three wishes as an adult.
Oh, you think he did go back?
To go back and live his life
over with an adult mind.
'Cause if you think about it--
I think that's right.
Every conversation you ever had with him,
every choice that he made--
It's like, man, you're right.
He's like--
You're mature.
This dude is playing this
game of life like it's a game.
And like he knows how to win it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, he's not intimidated by stuff.
And he was a year younger than us
because he had skipped a grade.
And when he came back as an adult,
he decided I'm also going to skip a grade.
'Cause I'm impatient.
He was a year younger than us.
But yet,
he was navigating all these
things and then telling us.
And what he told me--
And in high school he was
dating women two years
and three years older than him.
Yeah, he was dating the girls
that every guy in the
school wanted to date,
and he just showed up
and was like, "Well,"
"I'm gonna date them now
because I am an adult.
"I have been sent from the future!"
That is the only explanation.
Oh my gosh.
It works, doesn't it?
That's right.
We need to call him.
Because Juby is such an,
I mean, maybe he's an alien,
that's an alien name.
It's made-up.
Yeah, it's probably not--
You ever heard of anybody
whose last name is Juby, J-U-B-Y?
Yeah, that's definitely a name.
He was asked, "What do
you want your name to be?"
"Juby."
It was like, "Only thing
I can think of right now."
And when I take human form
and travel in the past.
So he was an alien who lived a life
and then went back and relived it?
Or he was given three wishes as an adult
and he was like, "I only need one."
All of the above.
"And it's to go back
"with this mind and relive my life."
That's my theory.
And what Michael told me,
he just was like, you know,
"You just gotta be relaxed
and you need to make it count,
"and you need to literally count."
Right?
Like he wanted me to count
how long the kiss was
so I could report back.
Yeah, he counted for me.
And because he wasn't there, I lost heart,
I guess, at seven seconds.
But you did have this
conversation with him?
Yeah.
He told me the things.
He had a connection to Dunn, right?
Because I think his parents were members
of the Chicora Country Club or something,
and there was like a connection to Dunn.
Actually, I think his mom was teaching.
She was teaching at Triton, right?
That's right.
That was it.
And so Dunn was like the city, right?
They had a movie theater,
which I also kissed Amber at,
but they had a Chinese restaurant.
They had an interstate.
Right.
It's the crack capital of the world.
Yeah, I think there was a crack problem.
But he had this insight into
what the kids at Dunn
Middle School were doing.
And when he told me
what the kids at Dunn
Middle School were doing--
Yeah, like sex in the hallways type stuff?
I just realized that I
was way behind the curve.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, there was things happening.
People were discovering things
about each other's bodies
in ways that us kids in
Buies Creek didn't know
was even possible.
So when he told me these
things, I was just like,
"Whoa, okay, all right, Dunn?
"Dunn sounds like a lot for me."
And I want it all!
All right, I want it all!
But that sounds like too much.
I'm glad I'm in Buies Creek.
Okay.
So when presented with
the actual opportunity,
what it amounted to
was a seven second wet kiss.
Oh, okay.
Well, then I'm gonna go
with nine for me then.
But there were many
more seconds after that.
Literal seconds.
Not that night.
In fact, no,
I think I did it again.
I can't remember.
It just popped into my head.
I think I have a memory of being like--
First kiss had a second back right after?
Yeah, I think so.
Regardless, there were
more kisses afterward
and never went to Dunn,
but except to visit her.
Well, you visited.
You didn't go to school at Dunn.
Is that what you mean?
Yeah, right.
But you like that theory
about Michael Juby?
We gotta call him.
I think we could get him to admit it.
Yeah.
Were you an alien and sent from the,
I think it's all of it.
Not an alien.
Alien seems unnecessary,
'cause aliens need to be educated.
This is a man who had
already lived a life.
He went back and did it right.
Yeah, so much confidence.
Quiet confidence.
It took us a while to get to your stories.
Carrie Green responded to our
prompt about first kisses.
"I was at Six Flags
with a group of friends.
"We ate some greasy food, then
rode a crazy spinning ride,
"then rode a ride called The Cave.
"A boy I liked leaned over and kissed me.
"And then he immediately threw
up over the side of the car
"we were riding in.
"Never lived that down."
Yeah, that's a tough first kiss.
That's traumatic.
Yeah, that's traumatic
when your first kiss makes
the guy sick.
Or it could have been everything else
that you listed before that.
I believe it was,
but at the time--
But at the time.
You know at the time
that you're taking that
and you're applying it to yourself.
We have another vomit story.
Breezi, cheezy_breezi!
"I was camping with my
best friend's family
"and her dad had recently remarried.
"Her new stepbrother had
been flirting all day
"and then suddenly lunges at me."
The sudden lunge is not cool.
No.
Nah, it's not cool.
"And puts his tongue so
far down my throat," ugh,
"that I promptly gagged
and threw up on him."
Wasn't my finest moment."
Okay.
Okay. I'm not a forensic scientist.
This is an unusually long tongue
and/or an unusually sensitive gag.
Well, I mean it might be the
thought of there's a tongue
that's been thrust into
my mouth by surprise.
So that can make you gag
even if it wasn't deep.
'Cause I mean, can
somebody get their tongue
all the way back to a place
where you'd choke on it?
I mean, maybe like a Gene Simmons.
I mean, maybe it was Gene Simmons.
I think if you really do
the 90 degree angle on the mouth,
the two mouths are totally opposed,
like a mouth-to-mouth situation,
and then you've really wide,
like snake jaw wide.
But that's the kind of thing that requires
the cooperation of two people.
And she doesn't seem
like she was cooperating.
And yeah, it's not cool at all when--
You don't wanna take anybody by surprise.
I mean, if you're in kindergarten
and you wanna steal a kiss under
the table or something.
I think that there are
certain circumstances in which,
and I'm talking about the
first time you kissed somebody,
there are circumstances in
which it's obvious everything
about the environment and
everything about the signals
that you're giving to each other
and everything that you're
saying to each other,
leads you to believe that it is okay
to kiss this person.
If you're longingly looking
into each other's eyes
for a prolonged period of time,
and you're having a conversation,
a romantic conversation,
there's ways to--
But I do think that just
asking permission is the way to go here.
Oh yeah.
Well, you did that.
I did that with Amber.
And it wasn't because it was--
Taught.
It wasn't because consent
was a buzzword at the time.
I mean, it obviously was in my mind.
I wasn't gonna do anything
that she didn't want.
I think in my mind it was more
I just want her to be ready.
It felt like once you ask the question,
then you have to do it,
I think is what was happening in my mind.
It was like, can I kiss you?
And when she says, yes,
it's like, well, it's
easier to ask can I kiss you
than it is to just go
in and kiss somebody.
That's what I was thinking.
Uh-huh.
But in a roundabout way,
I actually ended up asking for consent,
which I'm proud of.
It wasn't a pure motivation,
but I think that that is
the clearest way forward
is to ask.
Speaking of which, BYMBeth said,
"I went to badminton club in high school."
Okay, your high school
had a badminton club?
"I went to the club with
a boy I was dating."
"We were both really nervous
to have a first kiss,
"so we made a bet that
whoever lost the game
"had to make the first move."
See, this is taking communication and then
instead of making it
awkward, just owning it
and having some fun with it.
I really like this.
Here's the thing about badminton.
First of all,
the thing that you're hitting
is called a shuttlecock.
Yeah, so everybody's horny.
It's already sexual
and it's a co-ed sport.
So it's the perfect recipe.
And a lot of people think--
And you're inches from each
other's faces the whole time.
Really?
No.
There's a net separating you, I believe.
I was thinking, are we
thinking about the same thing?
You were joking.
A lot of people think that all
the business that's happening
is happening with like the football team
and the cheerleaders, you know?
No, no, no, no.
It's the badminton club.
It's the drama club.
Oh, that's where it's at.
It's the theater kids.
Oh yeah.
That's where all the
hanky panky is happening.
Oh yeah, okay.
So to finish this one,
and then the next one supports this.
She said, "He lost the badminton match,"
"but afterward he spent 20
minutes pacing up and down
"saying he was nervous."
Well, okay.
Once you had talked about it
and you reached an agreement,
then it's like, you just gotta go for it.
You can't be dancing around the ledge.
You got to jump off.
Right.
So she said that she
just kissed him first.
Well, because you had already established
that that was what was gonna happen.
But there's something about it.
You should build it up because that's fun,
but you don't want to build it up so much
that you're paralyzed.
Right.
But I want to dig into
this theory a little bit,
because I think I'm onto something.
And now, we weren't theater kids.
We weren't drama kids.
Or band kids.
I'll read this one
'cause this one's about band.
Oh, oh, band kids, big time.
Sarah A.
"Mine was in high school.
"He asked me to meet
him in the band room."
Oh, you know what's gonna happen in there.
"Up the stairs toward the practice room."
He's gonna show you his instrument.
"Where he told me to close my eyes
"because he had a surprise for me."
Okay.
Uh-huh.
"The surprise was him kissing me.
"We're married with two kids now."
Damn, that was fast.
Okay, I mean, I'm glad that
you're married with kids now.
And again, I think this
is a different time.
I would not advise this technique.
Yeah, don't.
I would not advise this technique now.
Yeah, yeah.
I think you gotta be a
little bit more open.
You can't say go here and close your eyes.
Right.
Go hide and close your eyes.
Yeah, now okay,
get back to this theory though,
because again, there's this
sort of cultural narrative
that you've got the jocks and
they're doing these things
and people are looking up to them,
but like, they're just hanging
out with each other all day.
You know what I'm saying?
It's these places where people
are mixing with each other.
And especially when you
get into drama and theater,
and now you're actually like,
you're revealing things about yourself.
You're having to dig deep into yourself
and access your emotions
for the sake of the art.
You add hormones into that.
Vulnerability.
That is, I mean--
Blowing on horns?
Give me a break.
I think, yeah.
Band is so sexy when you think about it.
Think about what's happening.
People are just taking these instruments
and putting them in their mouths.
They're getting the reeds wet.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, they're good with their mouth.
They're doing dextrous
things with their fingers
and their mouths at the same time.
I mean, this is foreplay,
if there is foreplay.
I'm just saying.
And parents need to think about this.
When you buy that trumpet for your kid,
you need to understand
what's about to happen.
Do you know how you play
a trumpet though?
So if you put your lips up to someone
like you're playing a trumpet,
it would just be like mouth
farting into their mouth.
I really think it's the
woodwinds that are the sexiest,
because you gotta put your
tongue out just a little bit
and just get a--
That Kenny G thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, the reason the saxophone is
the sexiest instrument--
It's 'cause you lick it.
It's not because of the sound.
It's because of the
reed and all the things
that you can touch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's it.
You could spend a lifetime
exploring all the new ways
to caress a saxophone.
It's so complex!
While licking it.
Whereas the trumpet is
just like, three things
and a sound, you know?
Hey, if you know how to
work those three buttons,
you can get some magic.
Now a trombone is a little different.
In and out.
Yeah, there we go.
The trombone motion is
the most sexual of all
the instrument motions.
Right, you put your mouth on it
and then you go in
and you pump.
You pump, yeah.
Wow.
You're not doing that
on the football field.
No, you're just catching a
ball over and over again.
And even if you just
wanna think about a flute,
now you're not--
I'll think about a flute.
You're not getting it wet
and you're not wrapping
your lips around it,
but you're delicately blowing
across the opening.
Oh yeah, that's still sexy.
Oh yeah.
The woodwinds.
I'm telling you, the woodwinds.
The drums?
What about the bass drum?
The drums.
The guy who just sits back
in the back and just boom,
just hits that.
Someone will make out with him.
Don't feel too sorry for the guy.
I mean, he's the loudest one there.
If he screws up, everybody
knows it immediately.
Hey, but sports you get sweaty.
I love the fact that when
we put out this prompt,
that members of the
Mythical Kitchen responded.
Nicole responded and said,
"I had my first kiss at a
park after my first day"
"of sports summer camp."
Okay, sports can be sexy, I guess.
"My mom found out and I wasn't allowed
"to go to camp anymore."
Well, and then right under this,
Trevor, also one of our members
of the Mythical Kitchen.
They call him an intern,
but he's not.
He's not.
He responds to Nicole.
"It was right after Napoleon Dynamite.
"We finished the movie and she was like,
"Do you want to kiss now?"
I love that.
You know, I love a woman who's just like,
"Do you want to kiss now,"
because that'd be like--
Hold on, but do you feel--
You know what, yes.
Like you need to clarify the fact
that this is made up from Trevor?
That this did not actually happen?
What do you mean, why?
That's not made up?
I can see that happening.
Do you want to kiss now?
Like when a movie's over,
it's like, well, you want to kiss now?
Oh, because you had put it under here,
I thought that Trevor was
replying to Nicole's--
Saying that he kissed Nicole?
No.
Yeah.
And he's just trying to be funny,
but he put his own story in there.
Yeah, it's his own story.
That makes a lot more sense.
Napoleon Dynamite.
I mean, at that age when
you were really wanting
to really start kissing,
it doesn't matter what movie it is.
It's just as long as it's a movie.
Well, this was not my first kiss,
but it was my first kiss
with a particular girl.
You were there and it was during a movie.
You gotta give me more information.
During a movie?
It was--
What movie?
The girlfriend that your girlfriend
was friends with introduced me to.
And then we went down to her
cousin's house or something?
The three of us went down to meet her.
Okay.
For the first time.
Yeah.
And it had all kind of been arranged.
Okay, you guys are going to
be interested in each other.
I know you and I know you.
And so it was kind of like our first date.
I do remember that night,
but I don't remember the specifics, yeah.
Me and my girlfriend,
this was junior year in high school,
her best friend was like,
"Oh, Rhett would be great with her."
And then you guys,
did you start talking on
the phone or something?
But it was definitely an arranged--
I met her for the first time
that night, in my memory.
I don't know
if my memory is correct.
Yeah, my girlfriend
set you up with her best friend
who lived two states south.
and we had to drive down there to see her.
No, no, we didn't drove to Georgia.
We drove to Wilmington because
her cousin was in Wilmington.
And so that night,
the first night you met,
you were making out with her?
Yes.
I work quickly.
Wow.
I'm a professional.
Shoot.
But do you remember the
movie that we were watching?
No, no.
What movie was it?
Helen Hunt?
You talking about the
tornado movie, "Twister"?
Twister.
It was "Twister".
It was "Twister"?
We were watching "Twister".
"Twister", that's romantic.
But I mean, it didn't matter
what movie we were watching.
I was like, well, this is
gonna happen at some point.
But you know,
for some reason,
and maybe that's just 'cause
I'm a student of the cinema,
I wanted to kiss her so bad,
but I was kind of into "Twister".
And I was like,
once the kissing starts
I'm gonna lose the plot.
Yeah, you kind of
lose the plot.
Bill Paxton, he was great in that.
Yeah.
And the effects for the time,
the effects were great.
So when did you kiss her?
During the credits.
Oh, during the credits.
That's good.
I think that's best.
So a similar situation to Trevor here--
The movie's over.
Do you wanna kiss now?
Right?
Well, once Napoleon
Dynamite starts dancing,
it's a long dance.
But we had done lots of hand holding
and my arm was around her.
And again, we just met,
but it was like everybody knew
that it was coming at some point.
But you had hit it off
and you'd built it up.
It wasn't the first time you had talked?
I believe it was.
Oh really?
I don't think I talked
to her on the phone.
She was like--
But didn't you date?
I mean, you guys dated for--
A year and a half.
A year and a half?
Yep.
Really?
And long-distance for a year and a half?
Yeah, I would--
You would just go down to Georgia
and visit her
or she would come up and visit you
and stay with my girlfriend
because they were best friends.
Yep.
And they were best friends
because she had lived in Bueis
Creek and then moved away.
Yeah, well, I mean, I knew
of her when she was a kid
when I was a kid.
Yeah, that long-distance.
We can do a whole episode on
long-distance relationships.
That was a whole thing.
Like driving to see your girlfriend.
But I mean, when you talk
about the bold moves,
I mean, Troy Wood, he said,
"It was in the back seat of
my girlfriend's parents' car
"with her parents still
in the front seats."
No way in hell
would I think about kissing a girl
with the parents in the front seat.
I mean, I just couldn't
bear the thought of like,
I don't know.
I'd do that.
I told you the story of holding,
I think it was Amber's
hand at the baseball game.
And then your mom seeing us
and me being embarrassed.
You know?
It's like, I don't know
why I was so embarrassed
about having a girlfriend,
didn't wanna admit that to my family
'cause any question about that would just
embarrass me even more.
I try to talk to my kids
about whatever it is
that is part of development.
I just try to talk about
it in a normal way,
because I don't want to
do anything to build up
things for them that
make them more anxious.
Because my blood runs through their veins,
and I wanna make sure--
I think you can only
tell them so many things.
Sure, sure.
I think kids are gonna be who they are.
But by not talking about it,
for me I think it's set up,
this thing was like, "Oh, it's a secret."
And when you're a little
kid and if you're kissing,
then you kind of
instinctively know it's like,
"Oh, we can't tell anybody about this."
Or like, Nicole's mom saying she can't go
to the camp anymore
because there's no telling
what you're gonna do.
Or I don't know what her
reasons are, but it's like,
oh, this is something to keep secret,
and to be ashamed of.
Well, I never kissed a girl
in the back seat of a car
while her parents were in the front seat,
but I do remember a girl I
was dating my freshman year
in high school,
her parents were driving us around
and we were in the back seat
and we were holding hands.
And then when her parents got out,
we went to the grocery store or something?
Talking about Walmart.
I remember this 'cause you told me.
Yeah, Walmart.
They went in
and we stayed in the car.
And you guys sat in the car.
And just made out.
And when you make out in a car,
the windows fog up.
And so we had to stop, open the door.
And this happened a few times.
And I remember you telling me
about this, reporting.
And I was like,
"Are you kidding me?
"They could come back at any moment."
What would you do if her parents came back
and saw you making out with
their daughter in the car?
Well, most of the time when
you're in that situation,
the person who is the
daughter or son of the family
that you're interacting with,
they know the deal.
You know what I'm saying?
She didn't say like,
"My parents would kill me
"if they knew we were
kissing in the backseat."
Yeah, obviously she was comfortable enough
with their response to--
My impression of her
parents is that they knew--
To fog it up.
They knew what was going on.
But I do wanna quickly talk about,
there's an infamous story.
We will not mention any names.
Okay.
But there is an infamous story of somebody
that we went to high school with.
And again, this is probably just one
of those rumors that happens,
but it was a rumor that we all thought
was awesome at the time.
He was a few years older than us.
Are you talking about we had a friend
who had an older sister,
is that the story you're talking about?
No, I'm talking about a guy who was two
or three years older than us.
Maybe he was a senior
when we were freshmen.
But the story goes is that
he was in the backseat
with his girlfriend while
her parents were driving
and they completed the act.
They had sex?
They had full sex.
Oh gosh, I don't even remember that story
'cause it was such a load of bullshit.
He and she,
according to my sources--
I don't even know who
you're talking about.
Confirmed it.
Well, when I tell you who it was later
when this podcast is over,
and I tell you who the guy
was and who the girl was,
you might be like, okay,
maybe it did happen.
I'm just saying it is one of those things
that's probably not true,
but if it was true,
it would be them who did it.
Listen, okay, now this is
a different subject matter.
If we're gonna talk about firsts,
we have to save losing your virginity
as like a different podcast.
That's a different podcast.
We could talk about that
as a different podcast.
That's quite a teaser.
Sammi Larber tweeted.
I don't know why I put such
a pregnant pause in there.
I think it's Lauber.
"My first kiss was a lovely
man who soon after realized
"he preferred men to me."
Or don't take it personally, Sammi.
I would say he preferred
men to all women, I guess,
is what you're saying.
"I had driven us home from a party.
"In my parents' driveway next
to my minivan, he kissed me.
"I wish I could make the
squeaky noise it made.
"He pulls back
"and he asks--"
Like blowing on a trumpet.
"He pulls back and asks,
"Where do I put the tongue?"
You know, communication!
I'm a huge fan of communication.
Where do I put the tongue?
Well, there's only a few places.
Yeah, well, what do
you do with the tongue?
Okay, all right,
you're right.
Because again I didn't know.
Again, it's like you thought
you knew by looking at movies,
but it's not an endoscopy.
You're never inside of the mouth.
You don't know for sure.
Like, oh, you can do a rotation motion.
Is it an in-and-out, is
it a down or is it an up?
I think this is how our minds
work differently, right?
When I thought about
kissing as a 14 year old,
it didn't strike me as
there was a correct way
to do it.
The fact that there's
a correct way to do it,
that's not the first thing
that pops into my mind
about much of anything, right?
Yeah.
It's more that there is
an opportunity to do it.
Just start doing it, you'll figure it out,
is kind of the way that I approach it.
And some things you get into
some trouble with that, right?
'Cause there is a right
way to change a tire.
There's a right way to--
You know there's a thing called dumb luck?
Well, I think there's also a
thing called dumb confidence.
And I think that's what you had.
It's just like thinking
that I'll just start kissing
and it'll work itself out,
it's like I envy that.
No, what I'm saying is that
this is the point I'm making.
There is a difference
between changing a tire
and kissing, right?
Kissing, you're getting into
the do I do the tongue like this?
Well, sure.
Do I do the tongue like this?
Also yes.
Do I do the tongue?
You can do the tongue however you want
because it's like an art form.
It's not a mechanical thing that has rules
that somebody came up with
that you have to subscribe to.
But it seems like you had a conversation
with Michael Juby about this.
I'm sure I did.
See, I didn't have any
conversation with anybody
about this 'cause it was taboo.
Well, I understood that
Michael was an adult
from the future who had
three wishes granted,
and he had come back to visit us,
and I tapped into his wisdom.
I mean, if you're gonna overthink it
or just think it through,
you need to be with somebody
that you can feel
comfortable talking about it.
Like, hey, these are the
questions that I have.
Where do I put the tongue?
You know?
And them not to laugh in your face.
And some kids have that
kind of relationship
with their parents.
Some kids have that kind of relationship
with an older brother or sister.
Yeah.
It doesn't always happen the same way.
But I do think--
Sometimes it doesn't happen at all,
and that was my case.
Right, I mean,
and we weren't talking about it.
The interesting thing is I mean,
I wasn't gonna ask you for advice,
and you weren't gonna ask me,
'cause we didn't know.
We were gonna ask Michael Juby.
But I didn't ask him that.
And by the time we were
in high school and like,
I knew how to make out by that point.
But when you were telling me freshman year
that you were in the backseat
in the Walmart parking lot
making out in broad daylight;
was it daylight?
Yeah.
It was daylight!
It was like, 2:00 p.m.
Wow.
I was just like, man,
that's far out, man.
But don't you wish you could go back?
Oh yeah.
As an adult man?
I mean, not as an adult.
That sounds horrible.
That's not what I meant.
Do you wish you could go
back with the mentality?
And I'm not just talking about
so you could kiss people.
I'm just saying that so that--
Enjoy life!
You were crippled by anxieties
about am I doing things right?
I had my own anxieties about the pressure
to perform and like,
I have to do this and I
have to follow these rules.
I have to be the best at
this and this and this
in order to receive love.
It's like, if I could go
back and realize that like,
no, no, no, you don't have
to play by those rules.
Yeah, that's the thing.
I didn't follow my heart.
I followed the rules.
Yeah, and I definitely followed the rules.
And you know,
but you followed your
heart a lot too, you know?
You were driven.
I don't know if it was your heart.
Maybe it was your wiener.
Well, yeah, it was in
certain circumstances.
I wouldn't say--
You had to impose
the rules over it,
but the rules were so firmly in place.
I just think the rules
were different for me.
But I was following the rules.
But my rules were--
You were very frustrated.
You have to do these things well
in order to be worthy of love, I think is.
And I think that you thought you have
to do these things correctly
in order to be worthy of love.
Yeah.
And so again, it goes back to the oneness
and the three-ness of
our Enneagram numbers.
But so I guess when you look back on it,
I was super motivated
and did a lot of things
and I did enjoy myself.
I had a lot of fun.
You did a lot of things.
You want to list them out?
Well, no, I'm just saying that like,
I took that drive
and I applied it,
and I kept trying to find the next thing.
So I wasn't paralyzed.
I was actually super driven to do things,
but I wasn't finding the
love that I was seeking
by doing those things.
But I was doing a lot of things.
But when it came to the kissing,
it was pure.
I wasn't trying to accomplish
anything other than
I was like, this seems
like the reason I'm here.
You know?
Yeah.
It's like, this seems like
the most amazing thing
that there is in life
is how I thought about it as a teenager.
And so I was like, okay,
I need to put myself into
circumstances where I can do this.
I was preoccupied with it, for sure.
I think even when I enjoyed making out
with my girlfriends,
there was just a lot of other
baggage that complicated it.
So it was never like,
oh, this is a pure form of enjoyment.
I mean, I felt guilty
as hell the whole time.
Yeah.
So that complicated it.
It kept me out of trouble, I'm sure.
But just my very evangelical
worldview at the time,
which again was,
for somebody like me with my mentality,
was also a prophylactic, right?
Because it prevented me
from just being completely
led by that mentality.
But I still enjoyed it.
It's just you feel guilty after the fact.
Strange times.
You know, but just to go
back to just the sweet purity
of a first kiss.
You know?
Let's go back to that.
I think it's just...
It can be sweet, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so I think if I would do it again,
it would be much sweeter.
It wouldn't be in front of everybody.
Yeah.
I think that's one thing--
It's like, hey, let's step outside.
I mean, later behind the Oasis,
like the Campbell
University student center,
like in between the dumpsters,
I think that was the first
place Anna and I kissed.
So like, my--
In between the dumpsters, yeah.
My third girlfriend.
It's like, boy.
It's like--
Good spot.
It really stinks at a dumpster.
It's not a great place to make out.
But no one's gonna show up.
But yeah,
not many people are gonna show up.
That one's better.
The interesting thing is, again,
like when I talked about the
whole asking can I kiss you?
It wasn't because I was
being super considerate.
It was more just like,
this seems like what I'm
going to do right now.
But the circumstances of the kiss,
it was at night,
I had planned on it.
She knew that it was gonna happen.
It was somewhat romantic.
Yeah.
It wasn't too extreme.
There was a fountain.
I asked permission, all those things.
I actually feel like, okay,
it's one of the things I look back
and I'm like, I don't have
any regrets about that.
I don't have any regrets
about my first kiss.
It's a good story.
I'm happy with how it turned out.
I'm happy with how this
conversation turned out.
Do you have a recommendation?
We gotta get back into that.
It's your turn.
I do.
My family and I recently watched a movie
that I think has maybe
been out for two years,
but if you're like me, you
did not see it originally,
and that is, "It's A Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood."
The Mr. Rogers story with
Tom Hanks playing Mr. Rogers.
I keep waiting for the
right time to watch it,
'cause I know I'm gonna cry.
What a wonderful movie.
And what a wonderful movie
to watch with your family.
Oh yeah?
We watched it as a family
and everyone was crying by the end of it,
which that doesn't always
happen to all four of us.
I mean, it doesn't take anything
to make me cry in a movie, but.
Did you decide, hey, we're
gonna watch this movie tonight
and we're gonna cry?
Did you they know it was coming too or?
No.
Well, I mean, we knew that
it would be a sweet movie.
It's not always easy to get
my boys to watch a movie
like "It's A Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood,"
but I saw an opening and I was like,
"No one's gonna die in this movie.
"So prepare yourself to be disappointed."
And you know, there's no explosions.
But you already know,
'cause I think you watched the
documentary about Mr. Rogers,
just how significant of a life he lived
and all the things that he stood for.
But the way that they captured
it in a narrative form,
and Tom Hanks is great, of course,
but just the format,
the way that they decided to
format it and tell the story
was just very compelling.
Just watch it.
Okay.
I'll have to watch it.
I highly, highly recommend it.
Do you think at some
point during the movie,
Christine and I can just start making out?
I would wait until the credits.
Okay.
But the credits, if I remember correctly,
were actually pretty cool,
and you'll be in an emotional state
where kissing is probably
not on your mind.
So maybe just do "Twister".
Okay, make out.
Do "Twister", watch "Twister".
Make it a double feature.
Watch "Twister" first.
Okay.
Make out.
Make out in front
of my children.
And then start "It's A Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood."
And then you won't wanna kiss anybody.
You just want to hug everyone.
#EarBiscuits.
Let us know your first kiss story
or how you've processed any of this.
Let's keep the conversation going
and let's keep this going.
No more breaks in the near future.
Well, I mean, at some point there will be.
Yeah, right.
In the near future.
But we're gonna be with you every week.
Same time, same place.
Maybe not the same place.
Maybe this place for a while.
We'll see how things turn out.
I don't know.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.